welcome to newark in Nottingham sure the
front line of the Tauri you kept
deathmatch after the surge of you clip
of the european elections last week the
government hoping to give nigel farage
of bloody nose meanwhile you Kip I
hoping to pop the toy balloon what is
immediately clear if the toys are
throwing the kitchen sink of this
campaign they're out and about
absolutely everywhere and the machine is
in full swing meanwhile you Kip seem to
be focusing their efforts on the town
centre their activists sorely lacking in
order to find out what's really going on
I met up with the candidates the nice if
slightly dull Robert genric and the
colorful and rather old Roger Helmer you
in a minute well I hope so obviously
we're not taking anything for granted
it's a by-elections always unpredictable
and this is a seat which was held by
labor from 97 to 2001 have been some
changes since then but it's not one of
those seats which is always conservative
so Roger you gonna win we think we're in
with a very good chance of winning I
think I'd be a bit rash to say we're
going to win but we think we can win do
you think that the European elections
have had an effect on on your support
sir I think they've had a dramatic
effect you could actually feel it in the
streets the morning when we're not so
much the European but the the local
elections and the news is full of you
get extraordinary successes in a local
election what I think I do offer is
someone who's never worked in politics
I'm not a career politician I've always
had jobs in whether it's a business
lawyer or running a business so I come
to politics I'm slightly different
perspective to some of the other
candidates who spend their whole careers
in pawleys or a big chunk of them do you
think that you give it over to charge of
Nigel was running this
namely in Canada I mean nigel nigel has
that sort of enormous box office
presents I'm sure he would do a better
job than I would right at the center of
this of this i mean the letter is from
Nigel it doesn't mention that you're an
MEP as well is there any particular
reason for us well obviously nigel is
the biggest face and the biggest asset
of the party you say you're not a career
politician you stood in new cars on the
line with 2010 you tried to stand in
Croydon this time round now you're in
Europe you have a carpetbagger on me I
don't think so I mean what I've done
since being selected it was you know
we've married two kids we have committed
to making life in basing our family here
your house we have we're living in South
well which is another town and a
constituency sure that your what your
taxpayer-funded assistant to Francesco
is helping you out this candidate my
taxpayer-funded assistant is helping me
to continue to do my work as an MEP is
during the time when I am here and not
in Brushy in Italian citizen she is an
Italian sir do you not find a British
person to do that job given the you get
message that we should have jobs first
well I know our message is that we
should have controlled immigration we
stand by that that doesn't mean we're
anti-foreigner it doesn't mean that we
criticize people for hiring Europeans or
non-europeans what's wits and square
properties your restaurateurs director
of that is that at the business you've
set up nope it's a way of doing a
renovation in the house for us tax
efficient way no not tool but
unemployment figures in this country
which shows just that there are people
looking for work here run and
the potential message of the european
election campaign was that British we
must come first I don't understand why
what's what selection process was like
your assistant you're trying to force me
to say that I'm prejudiced against I'm
not I'm not to say that I I hide her at
a time when I thought I was probably
leaving the Parliament and I opened her
a job for three months which he accepted
she's done incredibly well she's one of
the best decisions I've ever had I am
extremely happy with her work and for
that reason I'm not going to Jenks we
have an antique here without you to
value would that be all right it's very
rare and unique one [ __ ] p but what would
you price would you put would you
problems would you put on this one
limited edition a victory Toby jugg do
you think you will go up in value next
week are highly collectible Chris's has
a term of things like this which is no
auction values are you pleased to see
you get some first gay mep inspiring
extremely happy I've met David Coburn i
went up to support him and I'm hoping
pretty much you'd be down here to
support leave racial don't still think
that homosexual reality is abnormal and
undesirable I think David Coburn is
going to be an excellent Scottish meb
and I am delighted that we've got a
Scottish anything outside of my arms UK
Europe moving around well I've always
been a Euroskeptic you know I've been
pretty consistent about over the years
and I think Europe isn't working I feel
that even more so having worked in
business where I've seen the effects of
some European regulations the business I
work in today is heavily regulated and
has quite negative effect on I think the
Prime Minister will be successful in
renegotiation relationship and I hope we
can stay in Europe but it changed you
from the one we're in today so that
people find homosexuality distasteful if
our fiscal a repugnant I said that some
people take that view are you one of
those babe no or not